[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 nuestro invitado hoy es
leopoldo lópez el fundador del partido
de oposición venezolano voluntad popular
muchas gracias
muchas gracias marca
hace un mes el señor lópez usted huyó de
la embajada de españa en caracas y se
encuentra ahora en madrid con su familia
después de cuatro años en una prisión
militar un año y medio de prisión
domiciliaria otro año y media en la
embajada de españa porque irse de
venezuela después de repetir que no era
su intención
bueno primero que nada muchas gracias
por esta oportunidad efectivamente yo
siempre pensé siempre dije siempre
estuve convencido de no irme de
venezuela de hecho en el año 2014
en febrero el año 2014 yo
voluntariamente luego de que salió una
orden de captura en mi contra me
presenté ante la justicia injusta
sabiendo que eso iba a significar
prisión y estuve cuatro años en una
cárcel militar como lo acabas de decir
siempre había tenido la idea de quedarme
en venezuela pero las circunstancias han
cambiado y estoy convencido de que puedo
aportar mucho más a nuestra lucha por la
libertad de venezuela por unas
elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias libres en la que los
venezolanos podamos decidir nuestro
futuro desde afuera como decía ortega y
gasset el hombre y sus circunstancias
uno no decide las circunstancias las
circunstancias se imponen y a pesar de
que con gran dolor tuve que abandonar
venezuela como casi seis millones de
venezolanos han tenido que abandonar lo
estoy seguro la inmensa mayoría de ellos
también sin querer abandonar nuestra
tierra pues nos toca ahora abrir este
camino
dando la lucha desde el exilio desde
españa como base pero con la intención
de ir a otros países también a seguir
impulsando nuestra lucha hubo
negociación con el régimen de nicolás
maduro para salir
no absolutamente ninguna yo y articule
organice y ejecute el proceso de fuga
por mis propios medios no hubo ninguna
relación ni siquiera el personal de la
embajada y muchísimo menos por parte de
la dictadura fue una operación muy bien
pensada en la que se involucraron pocas
personas y pues pudimos ejecutarla
satisfactoriamente no es una ilustración
del fracaso de la estrategia de la
oposición de huir del país
mira no lo es lo primero es que es un
reconocimiento a que en venezuela de una
dictadura brutal nadie quiere irse de su
país y en venezuela yo no soy el único
somos millones de venezolanos los que
hemos tenido que salir la mayoría de
ellos en los últimos años y eso es un
síntoma de un país que tiene a su
población desesperada y en fuga y desde
el punto de vista de nosotros es el
reconocimiento de que maduro es lo que
siempre dijimos que era un dictador
brutal un dictador que ha sido condenado
no condenado señalado como responsable
de haber cometido crímenes de lesa
humanidad no por nosotros yo lo dije en
el 2014 y por eso me condenaron a 14
años de prisión pero hoy en día lo dice
la onu la comisión de derechos humanos
michelle bachelet y el consejo de
derechos humanos acaba de sacar un
informe en septiembre de este año en
donde señala que nicolás maduro es
responsable de haber cometido crímenes
de lesa humanidad y crímenes en contra
de los derechos humanos de venezolanos
ahora elecciones legislativa el sexto de
diciembre hubo divisiones en la
oposición
henrique capriles primero dijo que
quería participar a esas elecciones
ahora dice que no parece que hay
problemas de entrada de la oposición
para tener una posición común una
posición clara porque
mira lo primero es que lo que está
planteado para el 6 de diciembre es un
fraude no es primera vez que lo hace
maduro en el año 2017 se eligió una
fraudulenta asamblea constituyente que
fue rechazada por todos los países
democráticos del mundo incluyendo a
francia que tuvo una respuesta inmediata
ocurrió nuevamente en el año 2018 cuando
maduro pretendió reelegirse en una
elección que también fue fraudulenta y
también fue desconocida por más de 60
países y ahora vuelve a ocurrir lo mismo
maduro vuelve a convocar una elección
que no es elección que es un fraude y va
a tener el mismo destino va a ser
desconocida por la comunidad
internacional y también por los
venezolanos si hay un día una elección
podría ser con nicolás maduro
mira lo importante es que se den unas
elecciones en condiciones que permitan
que el pueblo elija todos estos temas
que te estoy diciendo es lo que hace una
elección libre es lo que nosotros
queremos
marc en el año 2015 yo estaba preso en
la cárcel militar de ramo verde en ese
año están contempladas unas elecciones y
la dictadura no las había convocado
nosotros hicimos una huelga de hambre yo
estuve en huelga de hambre 28 días
conjuntamente con otros presos y
conjuntamente con otros líderes que
fuera de la cárcel nos acompañaron en
esa en esa huelga fueron 28 días yo
perdí 14 kilos mis compañeros también y
esto te lo relató solo como una muestra
de nuestro compromiso por elecciones
libres nosotros queremos elegir queremos
que sea el pueblo el que decida pero la
convocatoria que ha hecho maduro
simplemente nos lleva un fraude y esto
incluso ha sido debatido en el congreso
y en la asamblea nacional de francia
esta semana se dio el debate y el
canciller
dio una explicación muy clara en un
contundente de qué son estas elecciones
un fraude y así lo ha declarado españa
también y así lo ha declarado también la
unión europea los estados unidos los
países de la región americana es decir
esta posición de que las elecciones
planteadas por maduro son un fraude
electoral no es que te lo estoy diciendo
yo pero sí lo es en el último gran
vencido de eso pero olor pero lo resalta
lo resalta toda la comunidad
internacional si hay elecciones libres
podrían participar nicolás maduro con
leopoldo lópez por ejemplo o usted dice
no es un criminal no puede
bueno nicolás maduró como lo dije
anteriormente en estos momentos está
siendo señalado por la justicia
internacional como una persona que ha
cometido crímenes de lesa humanidad
violaciones graves a derechos humanos
sobre esa pregunta yo creo que una
elección libre justa y verificable no
podría contemplar a nicolás maduro como
candidato ahora bien cuando me preguntan
eso la realidad es que maduro sería una
figura que perdería abrumadoramente
porque no hay una figura en venezuela
que tenga mayor rechazo que nicolás
maduro usted quiere más sanciones contra
el régimen nicolás maduro de europa en
particular
sí yo creo que las sanciones son una
herramienta muy importante que están a
la disposición de europa y también por
supuesto de eeuu de otros países en
particular yo estoy convencido que las
sanciones se pueden utilizar de forma
estratégica y en particular estamos
pidiendo que los nombres que han sido
señalados como victimarios como
responsables de las violaciones de
derechos humanos y de haber cometido
violaciones torturas encarcelamientos
ordenados en procesos irregulares que
son 46 nombres que están en el informe
de la onu nosotros estamos convencidos
que esas personas deberían de ser
sancionadas por varias razones primero
porque son responsables de haber
cometido crímenes en contra de personas
que hoy están encarcelados por
torturados o muertos pero más importante
que eso que fundamental que es que se
haga justicia es que sanciones como esta
a violadores de derechos humanos mandan
un mensaje muy claro que no habrá
impunidad que los violadores derechos
humanos no se podrán esconder debajo del
paraguas de nicolás maduro como dictador
y si estamos pidiendo que estas personas
sean sancionadas
europa y por el mundo libre porque tiene
que haber una raya roja con respecto a
las violaciones de derechos humanos
nosotros creemos que la impunidad y que
es continúe maduro haciendo estas
atrocidades en contra el pueblo
venezolano sin que exista consecuencias
es una terrible señal del mundo que
viendo y sabiendo lo que está ocurriendo
se queden de brazos cruzados job aiden
puede cambiar algo donald trump era un
apoyo clave para ustedes ahora con yo
bien tal vez va a cambiar te tiene miedo
mírala acá la causa venezolana en los
estados unidos ha sido una causa
bipartidista recuerda que fue el
presidente obama quien declaró a nicolás
maduro como una amenaza a la integridad
y a la seguridad los eeuu y fue esa
decisión la que le dio pie a las
sanciones que se presentaron durante la
administración trump nosotros por
supuesto que estamos agradecidos con que
se le haya dado tanta relevancia el tema
venezolano durante los últimos años pero
no podemos olvidar que el tema de
venezuela en los eeuu ha sido un tema de
apoyo bipartidista
cuando juan guaidó fue
el discurso del presidente trump sobre
el estado de la unión recibió una
ovación no solo por quién es él sino por
lo que representa que representa la
legitimidad la esperanza de libertad y
elecciones libres en venezuela y esa
ovación la recibió por parte de los
republicanos y los demócratas yo estoy
convencido que una nueva administración
del presidente electo biden va a
mantener el mismo foco estratégico de
tener que salir del dictador lograr
elecciones libres y revertir la tragedia
humanitaria que hoy sufre el pueblo
venezolano última pregunta
hubo en abril 2019 este intento de
insurrección no funcionó hace unos meses
después hubo esta operación el jede on
que donde hubo acusaciones contra la
oposición y contra ustedes de parte de
los organizadores fue un error de tratar
de tomar el poder por esos medios
mira son dos episodios muy distintos el
último que relata fue un 'falso
positivo' montado por la dictadura y así
ha sido señalado por las autoridades
colombianas con precisión con detalles
con nombres con fecha que fue una
operación infiltrada dirigida por la
dictadura sobre lo ocurrido el 30 de
abril ese fue un episodio en el que se
dio una manifestación popular un llamado
que hizo el presidente why do a sectores
militares policiales para que se sumarán
al apoyo del pueblo venezolano por un
cambio y unas elecciones libres
lamentablemente en esta oportunidad no
se dio el apoyo que se estaba esperando
porque hubo gente comprometida que no
cumplió con lo que se habían lo que se
había planteado sin embargo fue primera
vez que hubo una manifestación clara y
contundente por parte de las fuerzas
armadas y creo que eso es una expresión
de una realidad que hoy se vive que
todos los sectores incluyendo las
fuerzas armadas y las policías en
venezuela están en una situación de
descontento con la dictadura y quieren
cambio no tengas duda marc no hay nadie
en venezuela sensato
que no que no ustedes dentro del círculo
muy estrecho del dictador nicolás maduro
que no quiera ver un cambio nos toca a
nosotros construir el camino para ese
cambio y sobre todo que ese cambio sea
incluyente en el que todo el mundo
sienta que tienen garantizado sus
derechos en el que todo el mundo pueda
participar y en el que podamos forjar
una un nuevo periodo democrático de
estabilidad de paz bienestar y progreso
a partir de unas elecciones
presidenciales libres y justas
muchísimas gracias leopoldo lópez de
este madrid
[Música]